and it's not just
our people it's not just regular people
these are elderly
you understand yeah that's like that's
89 year old people like ah
like [ __ ] is wrong with people like i
don't understand what the [ __ ] is what
like any
like [ __ ] is attacking old
people
you know who cares what race they yeah
they're like yo how crazy is that what
kind of level up they stay all like
who the [ __ ] raised you like like like
what the [ __ ] you got going on in your
[ __ ] mind you attacking somebody
that's 89 years old bro like you can't
even are you [ __ ] dumb
it's crazy stupid it's crazy and and a
lot of
the way the media is spinning it is like
all black people are like that's a lot
of asian people feel like yo all black
people
hate us and i'm i'm like you know what
i'm saying i'm outside with
black people all day like you know
all the people who i know that um are
active on the
black lives matter movement are also
active like going to protest for
for the is it for the stop asian hate
and all that [ __ ] but i do think
talk about that narrative because there
is a narrative kind of going on right
now that is something between
because a lot of these attacks have been
african-americans on asians right
not all of them there's stuff in atlanta
with some white dude who probably got no
[ __ ] in his life yeah
um but a lot of it you see a lot of
these videos and it's happening
you know um is happening from the black
community
towards the asian community right let's
not say the black community
let's just say it's happening by
individuals who
yeah but but they happen to they not the
black community right right not the
black community but people
people who are black right you see a lot
of videos like that you know what i'm
saying
and i think that you know at the end of
the day
um
at the end of the day i feel like yo
these attacks
are not just happening from black people
towards
asian people these attacks are happening
i've seen videos white people doing it
i've seen videos of of of spanish people
doing it
it's everybody like you know what i'm
saying like it's it's not just black
people but you see a lot of these videos
happening
i don't know why you know what i'm
saying i i don't know why
i don't think that it's because black
people
hate asian people i don't feel like that
because i don't know because i hang
around black people all the time
i don't i don't feel that it's not what
i feel you know what i'm saying what i
do feel
is that there are a lot of people
who um are subscribing to that [ __ ] a
lot of people who need to be in these
mental
institutions you look at a lot of these
things that's happening right look at
that
in new york the guy outside the grocery
store right i think he was out of jail
for some crazy [ __ ] that he did
his mom or something right he killed his
mother everybody
everybody that's doing this type of [ __ ]
i guarantee not everybody but a lot of
these people man
uh you're seeing like crimes of
opportunity but you're also seeing
mental health
mental issues you know what i'm saying
and and it's not just going to
like it's not just the asian community
that's getting
[ __ ] up right now a lot of people
crime is up
it is especially in new york especially
in different place certain places
like crime is up people getting shot
every day people
and it's not just asian people like i'm
saying it's a lot of people
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on it's a
lot of [ __ ] going on you know what i'm
saying like you know
and and and i think that you know i
think there's a
we have to just be mindful of why [ __ ]
gets spun
to us why all of a sudden [ __ ] is just
like getting fed to us
why all of a sudden like you know all of
this
infamous like all you see all these
videos just catering into one group and
then catering like it's just you know i
don't know algorithm [ __ ] man right